hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and i used to
be a natural blonde however then my hair
disagreed with me and i ended up with
whatever this is but today we are here
to essentially soil ourselves with the
thought of another natural blonde by the
name of pariston hill because there are
many existences in hunter hunter that
inspire raw fear take the ant king
meruem as a prime example he represents
the sheer pinnacle of power meanwhile we
can also look to gyro who is the
embodiment of the true depths of evil
and then we can even examine fourth
prince sireidnik as one of the most
grotesque and twisted incarnations of
humanity possible they're all utterly
terrifying and yet none of them quite
concern me as much as paristan all of
the aforementioned characters have clear
motivations meroham sought the
prosperity of his species seradnik just
wants to make sickening art which is
there and gyro simply wants to engulf
the world in good old evil except i
guess it wouldn't be good it would just
be old evil but what does paristan want
and why will he go to any lengths to get
it and the answer to that question makes
me far more afraid of him than anyone
else so let's unravel the enigma that is
pariston hill and it's all going to
begin with a quick round of paris or
paris turn a very simple mini-game the
rules of which are as follows behind
this door lies one of three options
either the entire city of paris paristan
hill or paris hilton and it's going to
be your job to guess which one it is now
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to form a nen val by
subscribing to the new world review thus
resulting consistent injections of
hunter-based culture administered
directly into your youtube feed and if
you are correct then you'll get to spend
a day in whatever or whoever the correct
option was so which will it be paris
pariston or the other paris please make
your choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in three two one and bam it was
paris hilton because fun fact togashi
chose the name pariston hill because
it's actually an anagram of paris hilton
so if you chose incorrectly then you
know the thing to do and please do say
hi in the comments below if you are a
new member of our association welcome
now the first key thing about paristan
is that he is heavily underestimated by
the vast majority of hunter hunter fans
there's a prime temptation when thinking
about paristan to block him into that
stereotypical smart villain dude guy
role you know the kind of guy who might
not have the raw power to be a threat to
anyone but who can concoct genius level
schemes to get around that that sort of
thought doesn't come anywhere near doing
paris and justice what we need to
remember is the reason why paristan
became vice chairman of the hunter
association to begin with which has less
to do with his schemes and things and
almost everything to do with the
preferences of isaac netterer when
selecting his second in command netro
made his choice based on the following
criteria i want a hunter who's the most
difficult for me to deal with that's the
kind of right-hand man i want and i
found the perfect guy and let's just let
that thought settle in for a bit because
netero quite deliberately chose the
person that he felt had the most
aptitude to oppose him out of every
hunter in the entire association
paristan was handpicked by netro to
serve less as a vice chairman but more
as a direct rival and this is very
consistent with netro's personality we
have a tendency to remember him as some
sort of beloved symbol of glorious
humanity someone who sacrificed himself
for the greater good of goodness and
stuff but when you really examine it
nataro's life was full of almost
exclusively selfish choices he really
only possessed one core goal which was
to find a worthy opponent for that
purpose he focused the entire hunter
association towards developing this
opponent the hunter exam for example was
a brutal affair designed only to collect
the most powerful of potential gems and
i take the time to point this out
because netro and paristan are much more
similar than you may initially think
cheedle has a very worrying line during
the chairman election arc where she
states i hate the way that he accepts
and even suggests proposals that put him
at a disadvantage it's like he enjoys
obstacles he's a lot like chairman netro
in that way i hate it and also this
thought is later solidified by jing who
goes so far as to say out of the four
remaining candidates harrison is the
only one who really follows in netera's
footsteps so not only do we have the one
hunter in the entire association chosen
to be netro's direct rival but also one
who mirrors the former chairman spirit
albeit in a much more twisted way
because once again netro at least had a
goal in mind for his actions i mean it's
somewhat simple because all he wanted to
do was cultivate strength but it is
something meanwhile we have paristan who
follows a likewise brutal methodology
but with completely shrouded motivations
and it does get worse much much worse
because it is heavily implied and at
least on one occasion even outright
stated that paristan was not only a
rival of netero but potentially even
beyond the chairman's grasp geedal for
one refers to paristan as a monster
rather than as a human or a hunter
however fellow zodiac misaisdom came to
the conclusion that it's obvious that
not even chairman netro could control
him and that is a very worrying thought
because if netaro can't control him then
who can the answer is more than likely
no one paristan exists as an untameable
force and the first aspect of that is
generated through his understanding of
politics for someone who claims to never
actually feel any sort of emotion
himself paristan is keenly aware of the
desire of others and understands how to
manipulate them to perfection without
even expending so much as a single drop
of aura and one of the most tangible
showings of power from paris and comes
from this whole election process
throughout this endeavor paristan had
anywhere from 37 to 46 percent of the
entire hunter association solidly
backing him and to put that into some
perspective his nearest competitor
cheadle had a core support base of more
like eight to ten percent so paristan
effectively controlled the entire
association because while he did not
have or ever receive a 50 plus majority
the rest of the hunters were so
fractured into small cohorts that nobody
could stand up to paris and faction and
i want to emphasize that paris can
achieve this sort of sheer dominance
through the wonderful avenues of
politics and administration like nen
doesn't even come into it yet on that
note though paristan's brand of
existence in hunter hunter cannot come
to fruition through world class acumen
alone i mean sure netro might have
chosen paristan because it could have
been the administrative equivalent of
fighting an ant king however paristan's
capabilities outside of the mental realm
are not to be underestimated either to
illustrate he is a triple star hunter
which is the highest honor hunter can be
awarded in fact including paris and we
know of only three official triple stars
in the series and according to the hunt
hunt guidebook there are estimated to be
roughly 10 within the entire association
so they are exceptionally rare nobody is
going to reach that kind of glorious
achievement without some sort of serious
force backing them up and that doesn't
need to be through big punchy power
things either because then proficiency
and abilities can take all kinds of
forms for example i bet you never
thought that compound interest could win
you a fight until knuckle flexed their
math skills and the potential with
embarrassing to harbor any number of
insane nen abilities is equitable only
to other world-class nen users such as
jing and whilst paristan hasn't shown
any confirmed direct use of nen the
series does go to great lengths to make
sure that he is considered at the very
least equal to the rest of the zodiacs
if not greater and a solid portrayal of
this would be during the final round of
the election at which point nanika
healed gone the other zodiacs felt this
strike of overwhelmingly powerful aura
and you can very much see the panic in
their faces meanwhile paristan feeling
that exact same strike has a more casual
and even logical reaction because not
only is he unfazed by the feeling of
possibly the most powerful use of men
we've ever witnessed in the series but
he also immediately deduced its purpose
and even incorporated that into his
victory strategy correctly predicting
that gon would shortly make an
appearance world shaking power isn't
something that concerns paristan and
that concerns me he had no fear of
nanika and in fact no fear of netero
either in fact paris didn't quite
deliberately toyed with netero even
lamenting the fact that netro's death
took away one of his cherished play pals
and this is all before we get into the
true tangible power he holds which is
the fact that paristan just so happens
to have control of an entire chimera ant
army following the events of that
particular rock barristan in a process
i'm going to describe as somehow managed
to recover 5 000 hybrid cocoons without
anyone else in the association knowing
bah jing these cocoons then went on to
hatch into 5 000 nen wielding chimera
and human hybrids and to put that number
into some perspective if we take the
chairman election numbers as fact then
there are only 661 hunters total within
the association and that includes 10
punters as well so paristan right now
has an army of men users roughly five
times the size of the entire hunter
association so that's
well that's not good with one command
paristan could destroy the association a
thought that was confirmed by jing
during the dark consonant expeditioner
jin concluded that had the association
not responded to beyond natara's
provocation in the desired way then
paristan would have sent in his army and
annihilated the organization right then
and there and with that in mind thinking
about it there is currently no force on
this planet that commands more sheer
power than paristan currently does and
not only that but had he become the
chairman of the association then he
could have quite directly had the power
to sway global decision-making through
his words alone so why didn't he become
the chairman what does pariston want and
the answer to this is almost deceptively
simple jin quite clearly told cheadle
during the election that paristan quote
doesn't intend to win but he's not
trying to lose either which isn't just a
commentary on the election scenario it's
a commentary on pariston as a whole
harriston does not have a goal in life
previously i did equate his actions to
those of netro but in terms of his
desires he's much more similar to hisoka
hisoka lives for the moment he keeps
breathing to satisfy his own lust for
battle and paristan does the exact same
thing just in a much bigger playground
and well minus the sexual gratification
barristan just wants to play he has no
intention of winning but he will also do
everything he can to prevent losing the
key thing is he just doesn't want the
game to end and that confuses people
rather ironically to no end because as a
result of this paristan is more than
willing to accept new conditions that
put him at a disadvantage and that's
because there's no fun in it for him if
things are too easy so if paristan's
position is becoming too dominant then
not only will he accept new conditions
from others but he'll also more than
willingly handicap himself if nobody
else steps forward to do so but the big
problem with games is that if you play
the same one over and over and over
again then it inevitably gets boring so
paris and stakes in life need to keep
increasing for a long time he was
playing the other that's called the
hunter association game however that
became boring once netro passed away so
paristan has now moved on to a much
larger scale game where the hunter
association is but a mere peace so we're
now engaged in what i suppose would be
called the dark continent game where
we've got factions of the entire world
at stake which is pretty serious stuff
but uh but not to paristan his aloofness
during the election was quite amusing
because his decision-making really only
affected those with a personal stake in
the election however pariston's
decisions now are going to have
repercussions for the whole of humanity
and there's nothing really guiding those
decisions apart from making the game as
interesting as possible so if we find
ourselves in a situation where the dark
continent expedition is going like
somehow unusually positively well then
that's the kind of situation where you
can count on paris and to even things up
and conjure a dire challenge for example
if beyond expedition team are in a good
spot then maybe paristan will feed
information to the hunter association
just to balance the scales because one
dominant force with a clear conclusion
is boring we need to maximize the drama
and excitement for as long as possible
which means that paristan will always be
fighting to undermine whoever has
control at any given time but eventually
there will come a point where paristan's
involvement can no longer tip the scales
of the game and i guess what really
worries me is what happens when paristan
gets bored of that game what does he
move on to from here and how many
casualties is he going to cause along
the way because in many ways it would be
preferable to deal with characters like
meruem gyro or sirednik due to the
clarity of their goals however paris and
hill will always be completely
unmanageable he exists simply to ensure
that nobody wins or even loses for as
long as possible not even him in fact
especially not him so long as the game
continues he doesn't care and that's
what makes pariston hill the most
impossible opponent in all of hunter
hunter but for something that is
possible here is another video it's
about hunter hunter which is the thing
that you like because there's always
more to learn explore and experience
with this wonderful series so i look
forward to seeing you there